hello there miss coffee bean
the audience has spoken the last video
was about positional embeddings with
signs and cosigns as it was introduced
in the attention is all you need paper
you wrote us in the comments that you
want to know even more about positional
encoding
so here it is again a video about them
this video is about the question when to
add or when to concatenate positional
embeddings to the
initial input representation then we
will talk a bit about
learned positional embeddings so welcome
to this ai coffee break
your coffee infusion enabling you to
become
a positional embedding expert or not
[Music]
first let's dive a little bit into the
two ways to handle positional embeddings
in general
in the last video we showed the
attention is all you need
way where positional embeddings are
added to
the vector initial representation of
tokens
then we have seen what an act of balance
this addition
is by the way if you did not watch the
video now it is the time
go watch it and come back here for more
no miss coffee be not you you stay here
and do this video with me
so when adding positional encodings to
the vector representation
ideally they contain some semantic
information about the token already
but we would like to make the positional
information also strong enough so the
model does not overlook it
and also not too strong so it does not
overtone
the semantic similarities in that vector
space
a proof that this is indeed an act of
balance
is the division by 10 000 in the
arguments of the sines and cosines
finding the correct order of magnitude
of the frequency
is not straightforward and all these
problems come
why because we add positional embeddings
to word vectors
and risk mixing up information so
of course people have been also trying
other things to counter this
like concatenating positional embeddings
instead of adding them
this opens a whole new dimension of
possibilities
quite literally now the semantic
information has its own dimensions to
live in
and positional information is encoded
somewhere
else in an orthogonal those unrelated
space to the semantic one
this completely avoids information mess
but comes at a cost
memory parameters runtime all the bad
things
we could let the positional embeddings
have their own dimensions in two ways
if we have the parameter budget we could
add
extra dimensions for encoding position
in terms of
compute it's like going from bird base
to bird large
this luxury comes at a cost where these
extra dimensions will negatively
impact the memory and computation
footprint
down the line in the attention
computation and number of neurons
in the fully connected layer afterwards
the other option
is to take some of the dimensions away
from the word vectors
and use them only for positional
information this means
that the semantic representational
capacity of the model is reduced
it's like going from birth large to bird
base
so to take a bird eye view again adding
positional embeddings to word vectors
is for the poor but balanced ones that
do not afford
the extra model capacity but can keep
their position
on the thin line between semantic or
positional takeover
concatenation is for the rich in the
sense that they have
larger gpus with more memory or perhaps
are lucky with simpler tasks that do not
need a model with greater expressivity
to better capture
memorize semantic information
maybe adding and concatenating are not
that different
after all at least this is perhaps why
there is no clear winner here when we
think about performance on tasks of
added versus concatenated positional
embeddings what if
in these high dimensions that we cannot
imagine the word vectors and positional
embeddings
are almost orthogonal anyway so it would
be actually safe to add them
because the model could disentangle them
in the next layers already
miss coffee bean isn't sure about this
though but one thing is clear
concatenation ensures orthogonality and
no mix up
adding the positional embeddings does
not and it still seems to work just
fine with a little bit of tuning
and has lower computational cost but
okay
i get it you do not want to do the
tuning yourself so why shouldn't you do
what every machine learner does
let the transformer figure out for
itself what it needs
as positional embeddings let the child
or the machine learn by itself and here
we are already in the realm
of learned positional embeddings a realm
visited by language models like
bird roberta gpd2 and where image models
like vit
and deit have experimented too
especially when you have no idea about
how to handcraft positional encodings
for your data because you're working
with modalities that are not so explored
in terms of positional embeddings like
text is
why not learn them interestingly enough
this idea of learnable positional
embeddings
precedes the attention is all you need
paper and
aims to learn some vectors which you can
add to your input
with the same procedure as with any
other parameter in your model with
sgd and back propagation and hereby the
network
learns interesting and sometimes
surprising things for example
masked language modeling objectives in
bird or roberta
seem to enforce less structure on the
positional embeddings than
autoregressive models like gpd2
a model that must complete the sequence
left to right has more incentives to
focus on position
and we can see this in the cosine
similarity plot of positional embeddings
in gpt2
positional embeddings become similar to
their neighboring position
similarity which grows weaker while
going further
in the sequence but also long-term
relations emerge
with embeddings having high cosine
similarity to
embeddings farther away in a periodic
pattern
in bird this looks very different with
position embeddings
that have only a very narrow pattern
this kind of makes sense because
replacing a masked word
is much more dependent on the immediate
neighbors
but the thing with learned positional
embeddings is they do not seem to
consistently outperform their
handcrafted variants
the attention is only need paper tried
out learned positional embeddings long
before birth but it did not seem to
outperform their handcrafted
fourier-inspired
sinusoidal embeddings and you have no
idea how much sense it makes to miss
coffee bean because
it is very similar to the evolution of
self-attention
that was really recently handcrafted
with the fourier transform it seems like
research is going in a circle
rather a spiral because there is
progress but
look the original transformer paper
tried out handcrafted sinusoidal
positional encodings and
learned once but could not measure the
superiority of one over the other
then bird roberta gpt2 and so on all
came and advertised learned positional
embeddings
learned positional embeddings have also
been tried out in
the an images worth 16 by 16 pixels with
vit but also with no significant
gains over the default encodings that
were just
numbering image patches so again a loss
for the learned version
but let's zoom out a bit because this is
exactly what happens with attention 2.
learned quadratically scaling attention
has been haunting us for a while now
but lately there have been alternatives
like the ethnic
completely hard-coding self-attention
with the fourier transform
where the idea is super similar to
sinusoidal positional embeddings i don't
know but miss coffeebean sees these
parallels between the opinion
oscillation in the community
between learned or not so learned
self-attention replacements
and between hard-coded and learned
positional embeddings so
what are your favorites are you
following the church of
adid or the church of concatenated
positional embeddings
are you more a fan of learned or
handcrafted positional embeddings
let us know in the comments and as
requested by you the next video will be
about relative positional embeddings
it does not fit in this video because
your coffee break should
now already be over go back to work
or whatever else you need to do like
watch another ai copy break video
like and subscribe okay bye
[Music]